I think we can all agree the sooner we
decrease our reliance on fossil fuels
and develop new energy sources the
better whether you believe in climate
change or not the benefits extend beyond
just the reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions and the supply of oil and gas
will inevitably dry Tesla pioneered our
greatest hope in this space to date with
the development and popularization of
battery technology but as we've seen
they are struggling to meet the enormous
half a million pre-orders for the model
3 Elon self-proclaimed production hell
has resulted in delay after delay
Bloomberg estimates that Tesla have
produced around 12,000 Tesla Model 3 s
to date with the current production rate
of 1,000 per week which will gradually
grow to a target output of 5000 per week
but those at the tail end of the
pre-order line could be waiting until
2020 to get their model free this is
just the tip of the iceberg
last year 72 million passenger carriers
were built that's nearly 1.4 million
vehicles a week no matter how successful
the internet wants Tesla to become they
will never solve this issue alone and
the industry as a whole
likely won't be able to solve it with a
battery only approach the demand for
lithium-ion battery technology is simply
growing faster than the supply of
lithium can satisfy so it seems clear we
need a multi-faceted approach to solve
this problem another solution which was
the industry favored to take over from
fossil fuels not so long ago is hydrogen
fuel technology and companies like
Toyota and Shell are working to develop
this industry it won't be an easy race
but hydrogen may well prove to be the
tortoise that beats the hare hydrogen
has three primary obstacles that needs
to overcome to become a viable energy
source for any industry safety
infrastructure and cost let's get the
big elephant in the room out of the way
first I know it's on your mind if
hydrogen fuel cells are ever going to
make it to public roads at scale the
hydrogen needs not only to be safe but
to be perceived as safe and yes filling
a gigantic incredibly flammable balloon
with hydrogen is a pretty bad idea
hydrogen has a relatively low ignition
temperature and a very wide ignition
range for air to fuel mixture
percentages the fact it's pressurized
makes explosions are worried but it has
one massive advantage over oil derived
fuels it's lighter than air it can be
purged using emergency
in the event of a fire and if it does
ignite it won't pool around the vehicle
engulfing it and its passengers in
flames
Toyota even tested their carbon fiber
tank by shooting it with a 50 caliber
round the tank didn't explode it simply
let the lighter-than-air gas to escape
and vent to atmosphere hydrogen is
arguably the safer than gasoline so
safety isn't a huge concern for hydrogen
but the lack of infrastructure is
battery operated vehicles have had a
huge head start in this space the
electric grid is a prebuilt
transportation and generation network
for the fuel the battery operated
vehicles require and installing a
charger in your driveway or garage isn't
a huge challenge hydrogen doesn't have
such luxuries to kick-start the hydrogen
economy there are a few large scale
production facilities in the world with
the largest being Shell's Rhineland oil
refinement facility it uses its own
hydrogen production in the oil
refinement process but the lessons
learned from these efforts have allowed
shell and its partner ITM to make
hydrogen a viable option for uses in
energy storage last month I was invited
to London to witness the opening of the
UK's first ever hydrogen fuel pump to be
included under a fuel station canopy a
pivotal step in making the public see
hydrogen as an integral part of the
transport ecosystem what fascinated me
about this site was how the hydrogen got
there transporting hydrogen in
pressurized trucks would be too
expensive
as there are no large-scale production
facilities nearby and although hydrogen
can be transported within the already
established natural gas pipelines around
the world for use in vehicles we need
pure hydrogen so Shell and ITM took the
next logical step to keep cost down
they built a hydrogen production and
storage facility on site the production
facility is placed just behind the main
station and is capable of producing 80
kilograms of hydrogen a day the Toyota
Mirai is on site had a range of 480
kilometers with a full 5 kilogram tank
of hydrogen vastly more than a full
charge for a Tesla but you must consider
the huge upfront cost of batteries which
do not last forever in this equation for
cost I'll explore this battery versus
hydrogen dilemma more in a future video
but for now let's see how hydrogen
actually works the production process of
hydrogen is pretty simple
it uses a process called electrolysis to
separate water into hydrogen and oxygen
electrolyzer consists of two metal
coated electrodes and a DC power source
which provides a negative and positive
charge hydrogen will appear at the
cathode the negative electrode where
electrons react with the water to form
hydrogen and hydroxide ions these
negative ions now present in the water
are attracted to the anode or positive
electrode where they are oxidized to
form oxygen and water the rate of
production of oxygen and hydrogen depend
on the electric current but pure water
is not very conductive to achieve
adequate hydrogen production we would
need to increase the voltage or increase
the conductivity it's much more
efficient to increase conductivity so an
electrolyte in the form of salt is often
included as a charge carrier this is the
oldest and most well-established
production method for hydrogen for
reasons I won't go into who will include
reading materials in the description
this method isn't suitable for quick
response times with slow starter
procedures and safety concerns making it
completely unsuitable for variable
renewable energy sources which has
historically made hydrogen prohibitively
expensive if hydrogen has any hope of
becoming a popular fuel source we first
need to get it to price down to be
competitive with batteries and fossil
fuels this has been a major point of
research for the past 50 years and Pam
or proton exchange membranes at the
primary solution now coming to market
that are facilitating a realistic
hydrogen economy PEM replaces the
electrolyte rich water for a solid
polymer electrolyte membrane sandwiched
between the anode and cathode were
channels to allow water and gas and
solution to flow through as its name
suggests the PEM only allows protons to
pass through so hydrogen ions otherwise
known as protons now become the charge
carriers rather than a hydroxide ions
but the overall chemical reaction is
exactly the same while requiring less
voltage to operate efficiently and more
importantly has a rapid response time
making it ideal for integration to the
grid as an energy storage method and
this is where it truly dry sound costs
the hydrogen fuel cells and carriers use
this exact process in Reverse to power
their electric motors the cost of
hydrogen production by electrolysis is
completely dependent on electricity
prices if an electrolyzer cannot take
advantage of cheaper intermittent surge
electricity or use cheaper off-peak
electricity then it's losing out on real
savings and can provide the valuable
service of energy storage for the grid
but this hydrogen facility at the Shell
station can form an important part of
the Renewable grid infrastructure going
forward
hydrogen's greatest chance at success is
by fueling a new economy of hydrogen
where natural gas pipelines are
supplemented with hydrogen produced with
cheap renewable energy allowing hydrogen
to gradually grow to be the Earth's
primary energy storage method and
facilitating renewable energy to become
a larger part of our energy grid without
the worry of weather impacting energy
supply allowing nations to stop
depending on the importation of fossil
fuels and instead grow their own fuel
economy one tiny group of isolated
islands in the Bay of my home county of
Galway is attempting to do just this the
Aran Islands are rural irish-speaking
Islands Poplar Taurus for their unique
landscape would have historically
depended completely on the mainland for
fuel there are no trees here no coal no
turf no oil but what they do have in
plentiful supply is wave and wind energy
they are the perfect candidates to
develop a mini hydrogen economy an
economy where they generate their own
renewable energy and create their own
field to heat their homes and power
their vehicles who knows these tiny
obscure Irish islands could be the
birthplace of the world's first self
sustained renewable zero carbon hydrogen
economy thank you to shell for
sponsoring this video and inviting me
out to London to film on location if
you'd like to learn more about the
future of Transport Systems shall hosted
a live recording of the intelligence
squared podcast in London which you can
listen to with the link in the
description as always thanks for
watching and you may have noticed we
crossed a little milestone this week I'm
currently in Guam recording for some
future projects what went over
productions or Wendy as I like to call
them and Joseph from real-life Laura you
can get a behind-the-scenes look into
our trip by following me on Instagram
it's absolutely bizarre that this little
dream I had of creating a place to
celebrate the work of engineers has
actually become something much bigger
than myself
I remember messaging individual
subscribers thanking them for
subscribing and marking off every 100
subs on my chalkboard at home
thank you all for facilitating this life
of mine this milestone is just the first
step real Engineering has just begun
[Music]
you